bonjour thomas bonnet merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur ce plateau que
faut-il retenir de cette allocution
d'olivier verront hier on sait qu'il
aura pas de confinement nom et vos
qu'une annonce officielle en tout cas de
la part du ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand a surtout fait un point sur la
situation globale alors qu'un conseil de
défense s'est tenue hier la principale
préoccupation des autorités c'est la
situation sanitaire dans certaines
régions comme le grand test ou encore
auvergne rhône-alpes des élus locaux
avaient appelé le gouvernement à mettre
en place des confinement locaux pour
endiguer la propagation du virus
réponse du ministre de la santé hier
soir ce que nous écartons c'est l'idée
du confinement
nous ne voulons pas confiné à ce stade
annie agopian généraliser ni un
confinement locale la cre a en revanche
nous allons proposer une extension du
couvre-feu qui au lieu de démarrer à 20h
démarrera à 18h dans l'ensemble des
territoires dans lesquels cela s'avérera
nécessaire en abaissement de leurs de
couvre-feu à 18 heures qui pourrait
concerner une vingtaine de départements
dans les régions les plus touchées du
territoire une mesure qui peut
interroger de par sa pertinence est ce
que ces deux heures supplémentaires de
couvre-feu peuvent suffire à freiner la
propagation du virus
difficile d'en mesurer l'efficacité à ce
stade est abordée hier par olivier
verront celui de la réouverture des
lieux accueillant du public là encore
pad annonce mais une tendance
oui une tendance qui n'invite pas
vraiment à l'optimisme d'abord les
cinémas et les théâtres dont la
réouverture avait d'abord été envisagée
le 7 janvier rien n'est moins sûr
désormais les indications les
indicateurs sanitaires ne sont pas bons
et les autorités de santé s'attendent à
un effet noël c'est à dire une hausse du
nombre de contaminations dans les
prochains jours suite au réveillon de
fin d'année sans faire d'annoncé
officielle olive et olivier ferrand a
laissé comprendre que les éléments ne
semblent pas réunies à ce stade pour une
levée des restrictions et ce y compris
pour les restaurants et les bars censé
rouvrir le 20 janvier en écoute le
ministre de la santé ici début janvier
nous y verrons plus clair sur la
situation sanitaire mais
de toute évidence on pourra pas lever la
totalité des contraintes il y aura
peut-être des aménagements je pense
notamment un jour travaillé en
présentiel pour ceux qui le souhaitent
ou la rouverture de l'accueil d'un de
parts d'étudiants par petits groupes
si ce n'est pas à moi de me prononcer
les décisions seront annoncées courant
semaine prochaine lorsque nous aurons la
totalité des informations à date une
prise de parole qui intervient en tout
cas à deux jours du réveillon du nouvel
an et là les autorités montre les
muscles thomas oui au livre on l'a
réaffirmé dimanche dans une interview au
jdd il ne faut pas fêter le nouvel an
sous risque de jeu site bloqué le pays
pendant des semaines à cause d'une
soirée c'est la crainte du gouvernement
que les français bravent le couvre feu
et se rassemblent dans des foyers
ce qui pourrait causer une accélération
de la propagation du virus alors en plus
de la pédagogie tentait par le ministre
de la santé le ministre de l'intérieur
lui promet des moyens un nombre très
important de policiers et gendarmes
seront mobilisés pour cette soirée du
nouvel an écoutez gérald darmanin cent
mille policiers et gendarmes seront
exceptionnellement mobilisés
la priorité doit être donnée ces
prochains jours à la lutte contre les
rassemblements non autorisés et les
phénomènes de violences urbaines dans
les centres villes les quartiers les
zones sensibles les plus sujets à ces
phénomènes
alors il convient de noter que l'an
passé déjà cent mille policiers et
gendarmes avaient déjà été mobilisés le
dispositif n'est donc pas renforcé
seulement affectés à des missions
différentes parce que plutôt que
d'encadrer les rassemblements festifs
sur tout le territoire l'objectif cette
année est tout simplement de les
empêcher
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions